walking in the footsteps of the victims
half a century on people of all ages
walked through derry as others had done
on this day in 1972
they gathered to remember the 13 people
shot dead by british troops and the 14th
victim who died later
the march through derry was for civil
rights demanding an end to
discrimination against the majority
catholic community in northern ireland
and to the recently introduced policy of
internment without trial
it ended in an atrocity when members of
the british army's parachute regiment
fired more than a hundred live rounds at
unarmed civilians
half of those killed were teenagers
most of the british army leaders
at the time in the 1970s had experience
in kenya in cyprus in in the middle east
in aden
now yemen so so their their attitude
towards the people they confronted on
bloody sunday was very much informed by
those kinds of emergencies
an initial government report largely
exonerated the paratroopers and british
authorities
but in 2010 the extensive savile inquiry
found that the victims were unarmed and
posed no threat and the soldier's
commander had violated his orders prime
minister david cameron apologized for
the unjustified and unjustifiable
bloody sunday led to a surge in recruits
to the provisional irish republican army
or ira which led the armed campaign
trying to force british troops and
police out of northern ireland society
we reaped a terrible whirlwind
because the conflict
which was only in a gestation sort of
period even up to
uh up to the end of 1971
uh
became worse it was exacerbated
and
i would say that hundreds if not
thousands of people
lost their lives because of bloody
sunday
in all more than three and a half
thousand people were killed in the
troubles the three decades of violence
involving republican paramilitaries
loyalist or pro-british paramilitaries
and the british army
tirelessly
across the decades you have toiled to
clear your loved ones names
last year british prosecutors announced
the only british soldier charged with
murder would not face trial and the uk
government's pushing legislation that
according to its critics amounts to an
amnesty for all killings during the
troubles including by security forces
michael bridge many of those who lost
loved ones on bloody sunday say they're
still fighting for justice
nadine barber al jazeera